first of all i want to say i love that
wolf painting behind you
when you have the combination of the
wolf
your buzz cut your and and then that
evil
beard you are a fierce fierce guy on
zoom
you were the fiercest zoom call i've
ever had fantastic
yes yes it's
it's amazing um can you know where i
could get a wolf
painting i need a wolf painting behind
me because
this this isn't doing it i need that
fierce yelling wolf
you know what's crazy i had this
commission back in the true blood days
this was my wolf
from true blood my wolf thunder that i
used to transform into
i had a bunch of pictures i took a bunch
of pictures of them and sent them off to
a painter that i was introduced to and
and this came out this is a one-of-one
but
it's funny you say that because i could
just call that painter up and have them
paint you won't
yeah but i don't think a wolf works for
you i think i need a frightened
uh lemur you know like a friend i've got
an idea
i've got an idea oh
who's this this is wait this is your new
this is your dog bubbles is that right
yeah that's right this is bubbles this
is bubbles bubbles is
how long have you had bubbles for about
a year and a half
look at the wolf is trying to eat
bubbles that's the optical illusion
right now
bubbles is running from but that's your
painting this is your painting
i'm more of a bubbles guy what a cute
let's talk about bubbles for a second
because uh i know you post a lot of
photos of bubbles
you've got this picture you put up
of um bubbles your dog sort of as baby
yoda
very nice do they get along uh she
doesn't really like
baby yoda i think she's uh maybe jealous
of baby yoda
that maybe we're going to hug baby yoda
and feed baby yoda more than her
it's going to start taking up more
attention so there's a rivalry brewing
between
the the two i understand there's another
rivalry which is
correct me if i'm wrong uh that bubbles
kind of prefers you to sofia is that
right
yeah that's right uh chihuahuas are
notorious for just picking
somebody's that they pick a person and
she picked me right away when the
shelter brought her over she actually
jumped away from the shelter people
ran over to me to pick her up and then
started growling at the people from the
shelter like go away
and then sophia tried to grab her she
growled at sofia
really so bubbles doesn't like sophia
but prefers you
she likes sophia now sophia is uh
feeds her a lot and uh and she likes
that so anytime sophia's in the kitchen
she'll run around because she knows
there's gonna be some food
but otherwise yeah it's uh it's uh
sophia's been a little bit jealous yeah
you know
um i have to say uh joe i can relate
because the first time i met you guys
my immediate attraction was to you and i
was very hostile to sophia
they say that tall irish people
pick someone and then you're their
person
yes and i i totally understand that
um so i i actually i've a lot of people
out there
they don't know that i i sometimes i
will hold conan like this
conan will give me his belly and i will
just rub
conan's belly and feed him treats
whenever i get up
everyone in my world says you gotta go
to joe's house and let him hold you and
rub your belly and i do
and i immediately calm down yes yes
yeah it's that way yeah yeah yeah yeah
let's uh